gleich zu beginn aber sind wir verbunden
mit johannes hano kunden haben nach new
york schönen guten abend johannes
johannes wiest denn der aktuelle stand
hatte donald trump seine niederlage
mittlerweile eingestanden
nein
donald trump hat schon gleich nach den
wahlen den sprengsatz an die
amerikanische demokratie gelegt und er
hat jetzt die zündschnur angezündet also
das ganze wird dir sehr gefährlich
werden aus meiner sicht denn donald
trump ist nach wie vor nicht bereit die
waren die niederlage einzugestehen
joe biden liegt uneinholbar vorn auch
jetzt wird noch ein bis zwei prozent der
stimmen ausgezählt das gibt's keine
chance für donald trump ihnen dann noch
einzuholen aber er delegitimiert die
waren das scheint die strategie zu sein
er hat heute noch mal wieder getwittert
wir werden gewinnen und er wird dabei
flankiert von vielen prominenten
republikaner lindsey graham einer der
prominentesten senatoren hier
unterstützt mich und sagt wenn wir
nichts gegen die briefwahl unternehmen
dann werden wir in zukunft kein
republikaner mehr hier gewählt bekommen
und da ist die strategie völlig klar man
hat angst dass über die briefwahlen in
zukunft tatsächlich die republikaner
keine chancen haben und man versucht
jetzt klar zu machen dass das alles
betrug ist und macht den demokraten
betrug vater hat sich nichts geändert
und das wird glaube ich sehr gefährlich
sind
salz skurrile groteske szenen die sich
auch im amerikanischen fernsehen
abspielen johannes gibt das mehrfach
jetzt gesehen dass kollegen der großen
networks einfach wegschalten während der
präsident sei der pressekonferenzen gibt
oder seine tiraden loslässt nachdem wie
man es nennt aber auch sein haussender
fox news geht jetzt auf distanz und hat
was ähnliches gemacht wir hören ein mal
kurz rein
das ist johannes ein einmaliger vorgang
kelly mcelhinney die da diese
pressekonferenz gibt und selbst der
haushälter von john fox news geht
einfach aus wie ist das zu erklären was
geht da gerade vor sich
also es scheint jetzt nämlich klar zu
sein dass selbst rupert murdoch der dort
treibt ja immer sehr stark unterstützt
mittlerweile auf distanz geht das heißt
das haben wir gehört gestern das ist
murdoch seinen leuten gesagt hat wir
müssen jetzt auch vom präsident die leg
sprechen man stellt fest man bekommt es
mit dass die demokratie in amerika auf
dem spiel steht dass man da nicht teil
sein will die um die medien erfüllen
eine wichtige funktion und fox news die
fronten tatsächlich immer unterstützt
angehen jetzt auch auf distanz
aber das interessiert den präsidenten
überhaupt nicht er macht auf twitter
einfach weiter wie zugänglich ist dieser
mann noch also wer wird ihn irgendwann
erklären was da passiert ist worauf
läuft das dann im extremfall hinaus also
der moment sieht es so aus dass er nicht
zugänglich ist und dass auch das oben
für die um ihn herum also leid führende
republikaner nicht wirklich zugänglich
sind man muss sich das mal vorstellen
was ich eben gesagt haben jetzt die grey
sagt die briefwahl ist ein
grundsätzliches problem da müssen wir
jetzt dran
mitch mcconnell der entführer im senat
sagt naja jetzt müssen wir erstmal ruhe
ausziehenden stellt das wahlergebnis in
frage und das verrückte dabei ist und
wie verlogen die ganze argumentation ist
zeigt sich daran dass mitch mcconnell
sagt ja wir haben hier ganz tolle
ergebnisse bei den republikanern im
senat und im repräsentantenhaus bekommen
aber die stehen auf dem gleichen
wahlzettel wie der präsident das heißt
also die die wahlzettel auch die
briefwahl sind und zur einen seite
illegitim und auf der anderen seite
legitim dass sie zu hause als gäbe es
eine strategie diese
präsidentschaftswahl anzweifeln zu
wollen und den swiss zu sehen in der
bevölkerung das ist wirklich sehr
gefährlich hat offensichtlich
mittlerweile auch sein justizminister
bilder dazu gebracht ermittlungen
einzuleiten und zumindest
unregelmäßigkeiten wie es heißt bei der
stimmabgabe bei der zählung nachzugehen
welche konsequenzen kann das haben
das ist auch ein einmaliger vorgang will
war soll angeblich unter seinen leuten
gesagt haben naja also er sieht ehrlich
gesagt keinen großen systematischen
wahlbetrug bamberg aber allein die
tatsache dass er das jetzt öffentlich
macht dass leute ermitteln können
seht weiter zweifel und stärkt sozusagen
die republikaner und die
republikanischen zweifel an der wahl
weil man jetzt sagen kann jetzt mal ganz
ruhig jetzt müssen wir erstmal abwarten
was built by herausfindet das ist ein
teil einer strategie um überhaupt die
legitimität dieser wahlen anzuzweifeln
das ist ja ich sage es noch mal extrem
gefährlich was hörst du johannes in new
york im speziellen der heimatstadt von
donald trump was hörst du darüber was
möglicherweise das ziel dieser strategie
ist also geht es darum gerichtsverfahren
zu verhindern geht es darum dass erhöht
man die deutsche bank kommt kommt und
sein haus verändert oder warum geht es
da also das natürlich alles totale
spekulationen aber sie gibt ihr das ich
habe gestern tatsächlich mit jemanden
gesprochen der der beiden kampagne steht
und was wir hier sehen die ganze zeit
donald trump macht nutzt diese zeit
jetzt in dieses hinterlegen und dazu 150
wahlkampf spendenaufrufe gemacht also
finanzen campaign vernünftigen aufrufe
gemacht an seine an seine leute und
viele spekulieren hier dass es darum
geht dass er möglichst viel geld kriegt
um seine schulden zu bezahlen der not
will diese zeit nutzen um möglichst viel
geld einzuwerben in diesem kampf um
genügend geld um seine schulden auch bei
der deutschen bank zu bezahlen aber das
ist natürlich nur spekulationen
jetzt kann aber auch sein dass
tatsächlich ein plan existiert diesen
diese dieses wahlergebnis für nichtig zu
erklären haben sozusagen einen arzt das
wird auch spekuliert staatsstreich von
oben zu machen geht um teils abstruse
summen die da im raum stehen werden uns
die kollegen der new york times die
irgendwann mal von 420 millionen
verbindlichkeiten gesprochen hatten gibt
auch mittlerweile die 900 die da schon
gerissen worden ist interessanterweise
haben die kollegen von cnn und
vielleicht kommt das einmal kurz zu
spielen
in einer reportage marc trampe
unterstützung nachgefragt und da
verfängt diese erzählung tatsächlich wie
hör mal kurz rein
[Musik]
sagt er ja einfach und die die
vorstellung dass da haben ungefähr 70
millionen weitere in den usa unterwegs
die das mehr oder weniger ähnlich sehen
was bedeutet dass johannes das bedeutet
dass diese leute hier in zwei
verschiedenen realitäten leben die eine
realität ist die die es fakten basiert
und da hat muss man ganz klar sagen es
gibt nicht einen einzigen beweis für
systematischen wahlbetrug das sagen
selbst republikanisches of state das
heißt diejenigen die in den
bundesstaaten für die auszählung
verantwortlich sind alle sagen dass es
gibt keinen echten beweisen donald trump
hat und sein team haben ja auch schon
praktisch allen verfahren bis auf 2 und
verloren weil sie es nicht nachweisen
konnten dass es das gibt was es aber
zeigt ist das ist eine gigantische
desinformationskampagne gibt über die
sozialen medien und wir haben das ja
selbst erlebt die leute wiederholen eins
zu eins was in diesen des
informationskampagnen gesagt wird was
der präsident sagt es gibt gar keine
zugänglichkeit zu diesen leuten denen
klar zu machen dass die fakten anders
sind das glauben es schlicht und einfach
nicht
das ist ein problem und den wahnsinn auf
die spitze treiben
auch da haben wir ein beispiel für
vorbereitet treiben radikale prediger
komplett beispielsweise einer der
einflussreichsten prediger in den usa
früherer musiker übrigens ein rockstar
der sich so zu diesen beim geäußert
[Gelächter]
hahahahaha
hahaha
h
aha
[Applaus]
also wenn es nicht so traurig wäre wäre
schon wieder lustig aber das lachen
bleibt dann ein bisschen im halse
stecken das ja autosuggestion und auch
gefährlich das ist extrem gefährlich und
diese leute wie kurbeln das sind reine
zyniker das sind leute die leben davon
dass man leute dumm dass man ihnen
irgendwelche geschichten erzählt dass
man sie dann aufrufen kann zum beispiel
kalkofe der hat seine leute aufgerufen
viel geld zu spenden damit er sich in
teuren privatjet kaufen kann
die brauchen leute die brauchen diese
falsche erzählung die brauchen diese die
sind sozusagen gläubigkeit der leute die
fördern sie weil sie davon finanziell
extrem profitieren und das hat mit dem
ganzen land er ist nicht der einzige das
macht also das hat kultstatus
und da ist eine rationale zugänglichkeit
überhaupt nicht mehr vorhanden was wir
da sehen ist auf ganz vielen ebenen sehr
verstörend und protest üblicherweise ist
es ja so dass eigentlich der präsident
der die wahl verloren hat dem der sein
nachfolger wird normalerweise
unterstützend zur seite steht
man unterstützt den präsident elect wie
läuft es denn in dem fall ab was wir
denn da jetzt passieren da im moment die
zuständige behörde und die dame die da
an der spitze dieser behörde steht für
diesen übergangsperiode gibt es eine
behörde die dafür sorgen soll dass diese
transition period snus abläufe so ruhig
abläuft dass man dem nachfolger die
schlüssel in die hand gibt er sein büro
bekommt dass man sie die neue
administration sich einarbeiten kann um
dann am tag ist auch gleich
funktionsfähig zu sein
die hat gesagt gibt es nicht die
schlüssel werde nicht übergeben denn
noch ist nicht klar wer die wahl
gewonnen hat oder das ist eine
kampfansage das heißt mit jedem tag der
jetzt vergeht wird es für joe biden
schwieriger einen ruhigen namens über
eine amtsübergabe zu bekommen und am tag
es dann auch tatsächlich auch nicht
anfangen zu können das ist brutal ich
weiß aus den beiden team das man sich
das schon ausgemalt hat dass man sich
darauf vorbereitet hat und parallel
versucht also in den griff zu kriegen
und dass man relativ zuversichtlich ist
das auch zu schaffen weil joe biden viel
erfahrung hat weil sein team das er um
sich herum aufgebaut hat sehr viel
erfahrung mit regierung hat aber das ist
natürlich ganz klar ein riesenproblem
für diesen orten
station sollte sie denn dann
eingeschworen werden sollte nichts
dazwischen passiert genau genau und
irgendwie auch eine bizarre vorstellung
dass am ende irgendwann wert kommt der
hausmeister oder secret service wer holt
den dann daraus aus dem weißen haus
ja das ist eine gute frage joe biden
hatte die ganze zeit gesagt also er hat
großes vertrauen in die amerikanische
regierung dass man unbefugten den
zutritt zum waisenhaus verwehren kann
aber jetzt müssen wir erstmal abwarten
wie das denn am 14 dezember abläuft dann
nämlich sollen die so eines elektronisch
den neuen präsidenten wählen und bis
dahin müssen die dinge geklärt sein das
ist aber völlig unklar bei den ganzen
gerichtsverfahren die laufen ob man dass
bis dahin alles geklärt hat das wird der
nächste wichtige termin der 14 der
dezember dann werden wir sehen ob die
beiden tatsächlich auch dann gewählt
wird von den wahlleuten und dann wird
man sehen wenn das passiert wird es
sicherlich möglichkeiten geben einen
ungebetenen gast im weißen haus heraus
im weißen haus herauszuholen bis dahin
ist alles offen und es ist ein
politischer kampf der hier stattfindet
bleibt in jedem fall spannend ergab
heute noch an anderen tweet da geht es
um den impfstoff über den wir gestern so
viel geredet haben und deutschland
beschwert sich sozusagen darüber dass
diese nachricht nicht schon etwas eher
an die öffentlichkeit gekommen ist weil
er vermutet dass ihm natürlich bei der
wahl geholfen hätte wie wir das in den
usa aufgenommen johannes
also da kann man muss man auch wieder
nach beiden seiten schauen es gibt die
eine seite denen er das zuspiel die eben
blind folgen die sagen ja das ist ein
komplott und die andere seite die sagt
ja was soll das also man das geht es
geht um wissenschaftler es geht um
ergebnisse
die werden dann veröffentlicht wenn sie
da sind und tatsächlich ist es ja wohl
so dass der impfstoff noch gar nicht da
ist er ist noch nicht abruft die das
dauert wohl auch noch wochen bis es
soweit ist das kann bis ende dezember
dauern habe ich gehört
also insofern auch da ist die
gesellschaft völlig gespalten was das
angeht und donner hat er einst immer
gemacht
er stellt sich und seine anhänger
grundsätzlich als opfer dar denn wenn
man ein opfer ist hat man jedes recht
alles zu tun um sich zu verteidigen das
ist die ganze idee dahinter
und da gibt dabei geht es auch um den
impfstoff das soll an einer legende
spinnen dass sich die welt gegen ihn
verschworen hat es gibt eine große
weltverschwörung in amerika gegen donald
trump und das versucht er mit solchen
vorwürfen weiter zu fördern also
johannes dante ganz herzlich bin sehr
gespannt auf das was john bolton gleich
sagen wird seine ehemalige
sicherheitsberater einer von den vielen
die im laufe dieser präsidentschaft
gefeuert worden sind hat heute eine zahl
gelesen 88 prozent seiner engsten
mitarbeiter hat dieser präsident in
diesen vier jahren gefeiert auch das
einsamer rekord dank die sehr herzlich
nach new york johannes wir sind jetzt
verbunden mit john dalton mit dem
sicherheitsberater dem ehemaligen
sicherheitsberater von donald trump
schönen abend wollten verboten wie
würden sie das verhalten des präsidenten
das verhalten donald trump seit dieser
wahlnacht wie würden sie das beschreiben
es war sicherlich nicht hilfreich
die amerikanische verfassung angeht aber
trump ist damit sich selbst treu hat
diese persönlichkeitsmerkmale immer
wieder gezeigt er wird also das haus das
weiße haus nicht mit anstand verlassen
ich bin darüber sehr unglücklich aber
wir kennen das ergebnis vielleicht wird
es einige
prozesse geben und es wird sicherlich
problematisch nach dem übergang zu
gestalten zu beiden aber ich glaube bis
auf damit schon haben eigentlich alle
inzwischen klarheit über das ergebnis
sie haben herr borken ein sehr
lesenswertes sind sehr langes buch aber
wenn es wirklich sehr lesenswertes ein
spannendes buch und speziell für
politikinteressierte geschrieben über
ihre zeit im weißen haus sie kennen das
wirklich von innen deswegen an sie die
frage wer sind denn die leute die ihnen
darin bestärken dort im oval office
sitzen zu bleiben
oder anders gefragt wer könnte derjenige
diejenige sein die ihm beibringt
irgendwann hat gefälligst für immer
golfspielen zu gehen aber das müsste
seine familie sein ob da jemand von
seiner kampagne oder im waldhaus dazu
geeignet ist also dass tom punkt wir
etwas auf ihre meinung gibt
die leute haben einfach angst ihm die
wahrheit zu sagen ich kenne das ja aus
eigener erfahrung wenn mit ihnen
unangenehme fakten versucht nahe zu
bringen
das macht einen nicht gerade beliebt
beim präsidenten halten sich die leute
zurück die
der auszählung zeigt das deutlich zurück
liegt in dem entscheidenden swing states
und die prozesse die auf sein geheiß
begonnen worden sind lift luftleeren
raum gibt es keinerlei beweise es gibt
keine belege
und wir haben es mit einer unabhängigen
justiz zu tun und da muss man natürlich
seine behauptung seine anschuldigungen
irgendwie belegen
wir haben bislang keine beweise gesehen
wird gerne mit ihnen einmal dieses zwei
szenarien durchspielen angenommen er
würde sich tatsächlich weigern das weiße
haus zu verlassen was würde dann
tatsächlich auch in einem physischen
sinne passieren er wird sich nicht
weigern das weiße haus zu verlassen
er wird in seinem kopf bestimmte
konstellation nicht vornehmen also eine
dolchstoßlegende etwa aufbauen
eigentlich hätte er gewonnen sind da
nicht betrug im spiel gewesen wäre wenn
man ihn den sieg nicht gestohlen hätte
war von inkompetent menschen umgeben
eigentlich habe ich gewonnen und wird er
kaum irgendwelche nägel einschlagen und
sich wird sich beschweren wenn der
ausgang war es nicht es gibt wirklich
[Musik]
verfassungsmäßigen institutionen die
dafür sorgen werden dass dieser konflikt
gelöst hat leute kollegiums trifft sich
am patienten und die werden dann ihre
stimmen abgeben und
die mehrheit geht
beiden wird mehr als 270 war leute
stimmen bekommt dann wird er seine
präsidentschaft auch aufnehmen können
wie ging es ihnen erbohrten in der
wahlnacht als er plötzlich vor die
presse tritt und sagt wir haben ganz
klar diese wahl gewonnen
wenn nur die stimmen gezählt werden die
legal abgegeben worden sind ansonsten
werden wir um diesen sieg betrogen
das war ja ein unglaublich würdeloses
verhalten hat sie das überrascht
ja das war schon beschämend
dieses verhalten aber überrascht hat es
mich nicht denn das ist typisch wer
präsident trump er hat sich immer wieder
so verhalten privat und auch in der
öffentlichkeit während seiner gesamten
amtszeit schafft sich die welt so wie er
sie gerne haben möchte und dann versucht
herr andere damit überzeugt zu
überzeugen dass sie sich auch in diese
welt gegeben sollen
und wenn sie anderer meinung sind dann
ignoriert er dass das ist so dass die
welt nur manchmal etwas mit der wahrheit
zu tun hat manchmal auch nicht wenn das
nichts nützt dann werden die wahrheiten
ignoriert deshalb ist es so schwierig
mit trump zu kommunizieren und was er
besonders hast in der englischen sprache
ist der begriff des verlierers des users
und er ist jetzt ein verlierer
mal ganz privat gefragt haben sie seine
handynummer könnten sie ihn anrufen und
ihm sagen mal auf ein wort es reicht
jetzt
wir hören da bin ich auf es wird aber
auch in seiner familie in der engeren
familie entsprechend aktiv war ich
glaube nicht dass die da völlig
abschalten
was er sich da alles konstruieren kann
also diese deutsch los legende ja er
wird zu dem schluss kommen dass er
betrogen worden ist
und da gibt es dann eine ganze lange
liste von den menschen die ihn betrogen
haben
und wenn er dann das office verlässt
dann wird er weiterhin versuchen auf
amerikanische politik einfluss zu nehmen
und deshalb ist es wichtig dass die
republikanische partei sich nun gedanken
macht darüber wie sie in zukunft
weitermachen will ich glaube da wird für
dann nur eine ganz kleine rolle dabei
herauskommen aber da wird wahrscheinlich
überhaupt in dieser partei sehr viel zu
besprechen sein
halten sie es für denkbar dass er ich
meine 70 millionen menschen haben diesen
mann gewählt
90 millionen follower bei twitter
beispielsweise das ist ja eine macht mit
der kann man was machen halten sie es
für denkbar dass er in vier jahren noch
mal antritt vielleicht mit der eigenen
partei darüber fantast ihren wird
darüber spreche mich aber letztendlich
glaube ich nicht dass er sich erneut zur
wahl stellen wird weil das risiko erneut
zu unterliegen
zu groß ist das internet er hat die
zweitgrößte anzahl an stimmen des volkes
bekommen nach hohe teilnahmequote an der
wahl wohl wahlbeteiligung gehabt und es
wird ja eine ganze menge leute zum
ersten mal wählen gegangen und haben für
die republikaner gestimmt das sind auch
eben leute aus der arbeiterschaft das
waren ja eigentlich die stammwähler der
demokraten
die haben mehrheitlich zugestimmt
das sind in deutschland leute die eher
sozialdemokratisch stimmen gehörten
vermutlich genauso es ist diese
wlan und verloren hat ist das natürlich
eine große veränderung
meine mutter war hausfrau mein vater war
feuerwehrmann wir hatten in baltimore
gelebt überall um uns herum wurde
demokratisch bestimmt das sind wirklich
gute leute und was wir auch machen
müssen ist dass wir die leute
zurückholen die tramps verletzt hat das
sind leute die an universität studiert
haben hoch gebildete leute wir können
das haben
es ist ja auch so dass eines stimmigen
weder stark für trump gestimmt haben das
lässt sich gut nachvollziehen denn das
sind häufig die fleißige leute das sind
leute die die republikanische partei und
ihre programme glauben also ich bin
eigentlich recht optimistisch bezüglich
des konservatismus in den usa die
republikanische partei muss sich neu
aufstellen ohne den klang vor allen
dingen wird es auch darum gehen nicht
nur diesem amt sondern überhaupt der
politik eine form von würde
zurückzugeben die kollegen von jimmy
kimmel also der bekanntesten late night
shows in den usa haben mal einen kleinen
zusammenschnitt gemacht wie dieser
übergang von einem präsidenten zum
nächsten in der vergangenheit abgelaufen
ist und das ganze ende 2020
[Musik]
so wie jetzt auch es traurig das zu
sehen
minister wollten wie wird sich die
nation bewirbt sich dieses land davon
erholen
[Musik]
ihre niederlage ein
ich denke dass amerika präsentiert der
versteht unser land nicht
also das ist ein schönes schlusswort ich
danke ihnen ganz ganz herzlich hoffe wir
sehen uns irgendwann mal in diesem
studio wieder
wir haben uns beide irgendwann
versprochen dass wir mal ausführlich
über den irak-krieg 2003 sprechen
das machen wir dann beim nächsten mal
ich danke ihnen sehr herr wollte nicht
ohne noch einmal sehr gern hinzuweisen
das war gar nicht der anlass für dieses
gespräch
aber es ist ein tolles buch weil es sehr
viel über amerika und die vorgänger im
weißen haus speziell in den letzten vier
jahren erzählt ich danke ihm sehr
herzlich
vielen dank dass ich dabei sein durfte